zusammen die heute plus hier freut nicht
dass ihr dabei seid ja das corona virus
hat deutschland fest im griff das
öffentliche leben ist schon so gut wie
lahmgelegt schulen und kitas sind seit
gestern geschlossen öffentliche
veranstaltungen sind verboten
viele läden mussten dichtmachen oder
müssen bald dichtmachen für restaurants
und gastronomie im allgemeinen gelten
ganz strenge regeln heute wurde bekannt
dass die fußball-em verschoben wird auf
nächstes jahr aber die warnungen aus der
medizin nehmen trotzdem nicht ab das
schlimmste kommt erst noch das ist so in
etwa der tenor der heute immer wieder in
die mikrofone gesprochen wurde über
dieses virus namens sarah scv 19 wird
jeden tag mehr bekannt aber vieles ist
noch unbekannt viele fragen sind noch
offen
gerade die praktischen fragen des
alltags und die wollen wir heute
versuchen zu klären mit martin stürmer
virologe und leiter eines medizinlabors
in frankfurt hallo herr stürmer also
größer sind wir erreichen sie in der
quarantäne was ist denn da los
ja ich waren vier urlaub haben und bis
dato hatte ich nicht gewusst dass ich
mich in einem risikogebiet befinde aber
dann kam diese fall meldung aus dass
dort vermehrt infektionen aufgetreten
sind und kurz oder lang hat das rk ii
dann letztendlich beschlossen dass ganz
tirol als risikogebiet zu werten ist und
dementsprechend weil ich halt eben in
einer medizinischen labor arbeite bin
ich in aussicht quarantäne damit ich auf
gar keinen fall an mögliche infektion
ins labor bringe und damit den betrieb
lahmlege testen selber corona virus und
das wäre tragisch wenn da jetzt nicht
mehr testen durften haben die kollegen
sie nicht getestet test läuft ja aber
negativer tests würde ja nicht heißen
dass ich mir nicht am letzten tag des
urlaubs doch noch was hätte einfangen
können
die kooperation zeit ist er bis zu 14
tage und dementsprechend muss man
natürlich die zeit auch aufwarten und
ein sicherer ein positiver test der wäre
sicher aber der negative tester wird
jetzt keine aussage machen die eine
frage die viele menschen einmal wieder
umtreibt ist woran merke ich denn dass
ich jetzt diese kurve 19 krankheit habe
woran
sie das merken dass sie krank geworden
sind ich würde anfang zu husten nicht
würde fieber kriegen das sind somit die
die wichtigsten leitsymptom es kommen
der ganze menge
weitere symptome dazu die nicht ganz so
häufig sind da gehört dann durchaus auch
der kopfschmerz dazu die
abgeschlagenheit die die muskelschwäche
atemnot natürlich dass eine extremere
klinik also alles was wir von normalen
erkältungs erkrankung auch kennen und
das macht das ganze ja ebenso ein
bisschen schwierig das zu unterscheiden
ich glaube immer noch dass es wichtig
ist zum wenn man aus einem risikogebiet
zurück kommt dass man dann sehr
sorgfältigen sich rächen sollte
wenn sie krank werden würden wie es dann
der krankheitsverlauf was passiert da
eigentlich genau im körper dass die
menschen teilweise am ende eine geringe
zahl zwar aber trotzdem dann auch
sterben ja das virus muss ja erstmal in
zellen reines kann sich ja nicht
irgendwo auf oberflächen vermehren das
wird zählen attackieren und in diese
zellen reingehen dort wird es sich
vermehren die zellen gehen kaputt es
kommt zur immunreaktion und wenn es wie
gesagt schlecht läuft dann passiert viel
in den tiefen atemwege und durch diese
massive belastung durch den zelltod
bekommen die menschen nicht mehr
wirklich richtig gut luft und das ist
kann dann so intensiv werden eben dass
es zum zum atemversagen zum
atemstillstand kommt wenn immer
hochrechnen das ist so eine zahl die
höheren grade virologen oder auch
professor thorsten nennt die in seinem
podcast der leiter der virologie an der
charité ungern aber wenn man mal so über
den daumen hoch teilt mit wieviel toten
müssten wir im schlimmsten falle rechnen
und mit wieviel könnte man rechnen wenn
man sagt dass wir bleiben gerade noch so
an der grenze diese berühmte wir wollen
die kurve unterhalten grenze dass man
sagt okay das ist ein glimpflicher
verlaufen also das problem ist wenn wir
die kurve flacher halten heißt es ja
nicht dass wir die absolute zahl an
infizierten verringern sondern wir
verteilen sie nur über einen größeren
zeitraum was wir damit gewinnen ist das
zu einem
gleichen zeitraum nicht so viele
menschen schwerst krank werden dass wir
unser system unser gesundheitssystem
überlasten und entsprechend die
intensivbetten nicht mehr zur verfügung
haben das heißt wir könnten über über
diesen über diese direkt das so ist
wir könnten mehr betreuen intensiv
medizinisch betreuen und gegebenfalls
auch retten weil wir vielleicht im
späteren verlauf der infektion
vielleicht auch wieder mehr wissen über
mögliche therapeutika oder vielleicht
dann doch auch schon impfstoff in
richtung bekommen aber das ist so ein
bisschen die hoffnung und um auf ihre
frage noch einmal zurückzukommen
mit wievielen toten müssten wir rechnen
ich nehme immer gerne weil es einfach zu
rechnen ist 50 millionen infizierte in
deutschland und 1 prozent sterberate
dann kommen wir auf 500.000 zusätzliche
verstorbene in deutschland im rahmen
dieser dieser pandemie
das heißt die damit müssen wir
tatsächlich rechnen oder können wird
diese zahl noch irgendwie drücken
sagen wir mal so hell wie gesagt es
schaffen das ganze deutlich zu strecken
und ein bisschen zeit gewinnen sind
vielleicht auch studien
medikamentenstudien fertig die uns einen
hinweis darauf geben dass bestimmte
therapeutischer bestimmten situationen
hilfreich sind um eben den schlimmsten
verlauf abzumildern das ist so ein
bisschen auch die hoffnung die ich habe
die studien die ersten werden
wahrscheinlich ende april ergebnisse
liefern und dann hängt es natürlich darf
auch das medikament in ausreichender
menge zur verfügung steht es ist
initialen mal für ebola getestet worden
und ist nicht großartig produziert
worden also da man natürlich ein kleines
problem
die lage ist ja tatsächlich ernst muss
man sagen die warnungen der mediziner
gehen nach oben
das robert-koch-institut hat
gefahrenlage heute hoch gestuft gehören
mal kurz den o-ton dazu wir werden heute
die risikoeinschätzung für die
gesundheit der bevölkerung in
deutschland ändern
wir werden sie auch heute als hoch
einschätzen
das der grund warum die gestern
verkündeten maßnahmen getroffen wurden
und diese maßnahmen haben den zweck dass
sie die ausbreitung des virus
verlangsamt ohne diese maßnahmen müssen
wir davon ausgehen dass wir in wenigen
monaten vielleicht mehrere millionen
krankheitsfälle haben mehrere millionen
krankheitsfälle das ist aber das wovon
sie ausgehen 50 millionen erkrankte
infizierte also infiziert oder krank das
muss man differenzieren
genau 50 millionen infizierte davon
werden nur 20 krank richtig krank und
davon von diesen 20 5 prozent
die tatsächlich intensivmedizinische
betreuung notwendig haben also dann
würden wir von rund zweieinhalb
millionen patienten reden und wie gesagt
was wir machen wollen durch diese
maßnahmen die jetzt ergriffen worden
sind ist dass diese zweieinhalb
millionen eben nicht innerhalb von vier
wochen in die krankenhäuser geflutet
werden sondern dass sie über einen viel
größeren zeitraum in die krankenhäuser
kommen um eben die kapazitätsgrenze
nicht zu überschreiten haben sie dann
armen war es für den zeitraum dass sein
müsste bei zweieinhalb millionen
menschen in krankenhäuser und das klingt
enorm
muss ich jetzt kann ich jetzt nicht
genau sagen wie viel prozent wer
letztendlich von der spitze runterkommen
über welchen zeitraum jetzt verteilen
müssen weil ich die aktuelle zahl der
intensivbetten nicht im kopf habe es
kommt natürlich auch dazu dass die
intensivbetten ja nicht alle frei sind
ja im blick sondern liegen ja schon
patienten und die können wir nicht
einfach rausschmeißen
sofern ist das natürlich von der von der
logistik für die krankenhäuser nicht
ganz unerheblich dass die halt schauen
welche möglichkeiten sie haben um eben
die die bettenanzahl zur verfügung zu
stellen die wir wirklich brauchen
der stürmer der schau mal in die
kommentare weil hier laufen ihre sind
wie viele fragen einen teilweise sehr
speziell da können wir jetzt nicht
beantworten
teilweise aber auch ganz praktisch hier
zum beispiel wie kann man sich als
kassierer im lebensmittelbereich
schützen möchte doris grass wissen
gerade diese menschen sind ja da noch
sehr betroffen weil sie mit vielen
leuten in kontakt sind und auch bleiben
müssen weil wir wollen die supermärkte
ja nicht schließen
so ist es das ist natürlich die frage
die man häufig hört die kassiererinnen
die verkäuferin die halt eben noch
arbeiten müssen und mich nicht
ausweichen können ja und die zwei meter
abstand die wir ja immer propagieren
wird natürlich im geschäft auch
schwierig spätestens an der kasse kann
ich mich daran hat mich nicht daran
erinnern jemals zwei meter abstand zur
kassiererin einhalten zu können
schützen insofern ist schwierig die
hygiene ist natürlich immer wichtig so
ein bisschen darauf zu achten wer
besteht und sitzt der oder westwerk weg
kommt er als kunde und ich hoffe dass
diejenigen welche die zumindest die
symptome haben diszipliniert genug sind
zu hause zu bleiben um eben auch ihrer
verantwortung gerecht zu werden nicht
andere menschen anzustecken
die sich schwer schützen können es
bleibt dabei zugucken häufig dann auch
trotzdem die hände zu waschen und
möglichst hat eben zu vermeiden wenn
wirklich jemand in die richtung ist
möglichst schnell vielleicht auch zur
seite zu gehen das klingt vielleicht
platzt aber viel mehr möglichkeiten sehe
ich da nicht es gibt ja eine frage die
immer wieder auftaucht nämlich wie lange
können die viren außerhalb der
schleimhaut überleben gibt es
mittlerweile neue erkenntnisse ja es ist
die aufgabe am anfang studien die die
bis zum 9 tage haltbarkeit gezeigt haben
wollen noch türklinken
aber da sind wir sicherlich deutlich von
weg dann gab es weitere studien die
haben kontext von krankenhaus
oberflächen bis zu 72 stunden aktivität
des virus gezeigt letztlich muss man
wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen dass sehr
unterschiedlich sein dürfte
je nachdem wie groß die tropfen sind die
verteilt werden
wenn das kleine tröpfchen sind sie die
schnelle ausgetrocknet dass wir uns
schneller kaputt das ist innerhalb von
möglicherweise auch vom stunden erledigt
und die tröpfcheninfektion also durch
eben husten oder niesen darüber lesen
eher weniger die symptomatik des neu
kronors ist aber primär das auspusten
des erregers über die tröpfchen der
wahrscheinlichere übertragungsweg ist
und nicht die schmierinfektion wir haben
hier eine sehr gute frage von frank
düring auf facebook der sagte nämlich
was bringt das händewaschen
wenn wir direkt anschließend wieder
unser handy anfassen ich hatte mir
gerade hoch das ist ja doch der eine
ihren überträger nummer eins tatsächlich
auch im ganz normalen leben wenn man
keine coronaviren haben na ja gut das
hängt natürlich davon ab wenn ich wenn
ich der virus träger bin und mein handy
benutzt dann ich weiß ja nicht wie weit
andere leute ihr werden dies weiter
geben aber natürlich ist das klar wenn
ich mit mir die hände wasche und danach
wieder irgendwas anfasse
das potenziell also virus tragen kann
habe ich natürlich ein problem
wie gesagt ich denke der der haupt
übertragungsweg wird wird er sein die
tröpfcheninfektion und das häufig gerne
war schon wird trotzdem nützen und wer
möchte kann sein handy ja auch ab und zu
mal mit einem desinfektions zwischen
können sie mir dann vielleicht mal kurz
erklären das würde ja immer gesagt diese
masken die gerade die op masken die sich
viele menschen besorgt haben die ihr
teilweise geklaut wurden auch in großer
stückzahl wurde immer darauf hingewiesen
dass die meisten nicht helfen
aber wenn es jetzt um eine
tröpfcheninfektion geht also ich huste
und ich könnte das aus süßen oder ich
könnte den tröpfchen von dem anderen
einatmen dann können die doch also
irgendein barriere vormund oder der nase
ist dann doch hilfreich nach meinem
laienhaften ansehen oder nicht ja gucken
schauen wir uns die zwei situationen sie
sind infiziert sie sind krank wenn sie
sich eine maske aufsetzen und schützen
sie letztendlich ihre umgebung also für
den der schon was hat mag dass es auf
jeden fall sinnhaft ich sein egal
natürlich werden die sogenannten ffp
masken die die besten aber das ist denke
ich definitiv zu hoch gegriffen
also die einfachen masken werden für den
auch reichen natürlich musste man die
etwas häufiger wechseln und auch nicht
gerade auf der straße entsorgen
öffentlichen mülleimer vielleicht für
den dann nicht infiziertes ich habe das
am anfang der geschichte beobachtet am
flughafen leute die die maske getragen
haben sind so häufig ins gesicht
gegangen um die maske zurecht zu rücken
so hin und her zu wackeln
das ist ja genau das was eigentlich
nicht wollen dass die hände ins gesicht
kommen und insofern ist das nicht ganz
optimal und für die meisten ist
eigentlich die maske als sozusagen
negative um sich zu schützen
eher nicht geeignet ich habe heute im
zug gummihandschuhe angezogen die haben
tatsächlich diesen effekt gehabt weil
ich mich damit nicht ins gesicht fassen
wollte weil das einfach die ganze zeit
merkt man das ja ist das tatsächlich
auch vielleicht eine möglichkeit das
abzuwehren wenn man sich im öffentlichen
raum bewegt er habe ist natürlich auch
eine eine möglichkeit auf der anderen
seite ist der gummihandschuh wenn sie
den nicht häufig wechseln
wie er denn auch irgendwo möglicherweise
kontaminiert und sie neigen
wahrscheinlich eher dazu sich die hände
zu waschen
als vielleicht die gummihandschuhe
entweder zu waschen oder oder häufig zu
wechseln also das ist ein bisschen auch
ein zweischneidiges geschichte das heißt
häufig wechseln heißt alle halbe stunde
oder alle drei stunden
ich glaube da gibt es keinen kein
zeitfenster letztlich hängt es davon ab
wahrscheinlich eher wie häufig sie
irgendwelche dinge anfassen müssen zum
beispiel im öffentlichen raum also bei
öffentliche verkehrsmittel wobei die
fahren auch nur noch reduziert
teilweise ja der öffentliche nahverkehr
teilweise je nach stadt der
regionalverkehrs runtergefahren der
überregional verkehr zurzeit nicht eine
große frage die viele menschen sie
stellen es dürfen sich kinder
untereinander auch treffen und wenn ja
wie viele ist es mir auch bewusst also
wir haben ja die kindergarten und
schulen wurden geschlossen
um eben die kontakte möglichst gering zu
halten zwischen den kindern und kindern
und lehrern jetzt mir natürlich bewusst
wer selber auch ein kleines kind zwar
mit in der quarantäne steht aber dass
man natürlich ohne betreuungssituation
wiederherstellen muss um arbeiten gehen
zu können und diese gruppen die man
jetzt bildet sozusagen betreuungsgruppen
sind natürlich eigentlich eher
kontraproduktiv weil das waren ja nicht
vermeiden dass wieder andere kinder
zusammen hängen und sich gegen
möglicherweise gegenseitig anstecken
wie gesagt die realität ist mir bewusst
ist eine andere also optimaler weise
bleiben die kinder alleine ist es
natürlich schwer auch dicke dann zu
erklären warum sie sich mit ihren
freunden spielen dürfen das ist mir
durchaus bewusst die ja das wird auch
irgendwann schwierig die drin zu halten
die ganze zeit ja dass ich unterbreche
ausgehen glaubt mir schon sie sollten
man sollte halt nicht unbedingt auf
spielplätze wo andere kinder sind aber
zum beispiel mit den kindern ins feld
gehen wir haben ja keine ausgangssperre
aktuell
insofern kann man natürlich mit seinen
kindern durchaus an die frische luft und
das wetter lädt ja auch dazu ein
man sollte sich jetzt nicht unbedingt im
biergarten mit den kindern setzen oder
auf den spielplatz gehen aber raus gehen
per se ist immer noch eine gute
möglichkeit um auch da ein bisschen
dampf abzulassen ja ich habe wirklich
sehr sehr viele fragen hier werden sie
nicht alle schaffen leider waren unsere
zeit auch ein bisschen begrenzt ist sie
testen selber haben sie gesagt in ihrem
labor
gibt sind eigentlich alle labore
deutschlandweit dafür ausgerüstet oder
gibt es das speziallabor rein
theoretisch können dass die meisten
labore ich da jetzt kein überblick wie
viele labore letztendlich schon
beteiligt sind in deutschland an der
testung es gehört sicherlich gewisse
ausrüstung dazu also dass sie gibt es ja
auch keinen echten heimtest dass man
sagen kann ich mache das zuhause und
picken ergebnis weil es schon ein
bisschen eine spezial diagnostik ist und
das bieten vielleicht auch nicht alle
labor in deutschland an
aber wir haben den vorteil dass es nicht
ein zentrales testlabor gibt sondern
dass relativ viele labore eben
unterstützend eingreifen können diese
tests sind ja gerade natürlich extrem
gefragt weil viele menschen sich testen
lassen wollen oder müssen die
mitarbeiter dazu sondern auch extrem
gefragt manche sind leider in quarantäne
wie sie gerade herr stürmer aber wir
haben uns mal oder der kollege christoph
heinzle hat sich mal umgehört hier in
rheinland pfalz wie das denn da
eigentlich aussieht einer labor front
kommen darf nur wer eine überweisung
seines arztes hat und einen zugesagten
fixen termin der eigentliche
rachenabstrich dauert dann nur wenige
momente einzeln kommen die patienten mit
corona verdacht hier rein
gut 100 pro tag stand heute wir sind
jetzt schon die nächsten anderthalb bis
zwei wochen ausgebucht
auch in anderen landkreisen jetzt hier
in rheinland pfalz stehen jetzt schon
container beziehungsweise ähnliche
einrichtungen weil wir merken es werden
immer mehr abstriche rund 1000 proben
pro tag testen die mitarbeiter derzeit
auf coronaviren zusätzlich zum
weiterlaufenden tagtäglichen betrieb
doch das ist erst der anfang die
experten hier stellen sich auf
sonderschichten ein
die molekularbiologie wird personell
gerade aufgestockt ja viel zu tun für
mediziner und physiologen zurzeit wir
sprechen mit martin stürner biologe und
leiter eines medizinlabors in frankfurt
wir versuchen eure fragen zu beantworten
so gut es geht es sind aber wirklich
wirklich viele
wenn man jetzt bei den tests mal kurz
bleiben herr stürmer warum hat man nicht
frühzeitig mehr getestet um dann zu
verhindern dass die ausbreitung doch
noch größer wird als sie es zurzeit ist
ja man hat letztendlich glaube ich ganz
am anfang der infektionen gar nicht
gewusst dass automatische patienten
übertragen können insofern hat man
refinanziert und wissen sie kurz
erklären der patienten die keine
symptome haben also im prinzip ein ganz
ganz mildes krankheitsbild oder einfach
gar kein krankheitsbild und trotzdem
virus träger und überträger sein okay
gibt es das bild das auch und das hat
man nicht gewusst insofern hat man die
fall definition ganz am anfang einfach
gesetzt wer hatte kontakt mit jemandem
der positiv aus china getestet worden
ist oder wer war dort und gehört und hat
eine entsprechende klinik und gehört
damit zum risiko zum zu risikopatienten
die erfahrung dass es anders laufen oder
anders läuft kam dann später aber da
hatten wir in deutschland auch eine
relativ konstante situation werde eine
stabile situation mit dem einen ausbruch
in münchen mit den zwei rückkehrern aus
aus haan und das blieb über wochen
stabil insofern hat man glaube ich auch
gehofft
da wird nichts passieren letztendlich
war es ein fehlschluss weil
wahrscheinlich die infektion denn doch
unbemerkt über italien auch zu uns
gewandert ist klar nachhinein kann man
sagen hätte man mehr getestet was
vielleicht früher entdeckt aber das wäre
logistisch auch glaube ich gar nicht
möglich gewesen so viele menschen dann
eben entsprechend auch testen zu wollen
welche kriterien setzen sie dann an mir
reden wollen sie testen und wir nicht ja
das heißt im endeffekt kann es sein dass
kollegen hinter mir infiziert sind und
anstecken können und das gar nicht
wissen das können wir letztendlich nicht
ausschließen wir gehen von einer relativ
hohen dunkelziffer an infizierten aus
das heißt wenn wir jetzt diese diese
6000 fälle sind es aktuell die
tatsächlich identifiziert sind nehmen
dann muss man sagen das sind eigentlich
sehr sehr viel mehr in deutschland haben
sie eine ungefähre pi mal daumen anzahl
der fidesz sein könnten oder gibt es da
auch noch ein großes fragezeichen
da würde ich eher das große fragezeichen
setzen da möchte ich mich jetzt nicht
äußern oder würde ich auch
wahrscheinlich auch nur hausnummern
nennen das ist glaube ich zu gewagt okay
aber wir können davon ausgehen dass sind
eigentlich weit mehr menschen als die
offiziell bekannten da gehen wir davon
aus so ich schau mal hier nachfragen die
noch reingekommen sind eine frage die
immer wieder kommt ist wäre es denn
jetzt besonders gefährdet also
allergiker hier kommt asthma-patienten
hier kommt menschen die eine op hatten
die irgendwie vielleicht schon mal ein
organ transplantiert bekommen haben sind
das alles tatsächlich menschen die sich
jetzt ein bisschen besser schützen
müssen als andere
ja also chronische lungenerkrankung
definitiv patienten die aufgrund einer
transplantation immunsuppressiva nehmen
müssen definitiv krebspatienten und
patienten die kardiovaskuläre also herz
kreislauf vorerkrankungen haben
patienten mit diabetes und auch
unabhängig von vorerkrankungen auch das
hohe alter das sind risikopatienten das
ist mit herz kreislauf problemen
ja genau auch die sind definitiv auch
gefährdet da das heißt es eine relativ
große gruppe dann auch in deutschland
die wirklich jetzt aufpassen muss dass
dass ihnen nichts passiert oder ja wie
gesagt das risiko ist erhöht in welchem
maße ist letztendlich erhöht wird da
gibt es noch nicht allzu viele daten in
deutschland weil er natürlich da noch zu
wenig fälle haben um das statistisch
vernünftig auswerten zu können
aber klar die sollten alle ein bisschen
besser auf sich aufpassen und gerade
auch was die ältere bevölkerung angeht
nicht umsonst wird er gepredigt jetzt
die omas und opas lieber ein bisschen in
ruhe zu lassen und nicht mit häufigen
besuchen haben zu suchen hier gibt's
noch eine frage von walter müller auch
ganz praktisch kann man sich zur not die
hände mit industrie alkohol reinigen
oder ich will das mal hin zu reicht die
handelsübliche seife ja wir sagen das
ende waschen mit seife ausreicht
was die desinfektionsmittel anbetrifft
muss begrenzt wie wo zieht auch dem
desinfektionsmittel stehen dann ist es
auch gegen das neue corona virus wirksam
eine hoffnung ist ja dass dieser rahmen
jahres die warme jahreszeit die ihr zu
langsam kommt draußen schon hier in
mainz über 12 13 grad dass die dazu
beitragen könnte dass das virus sich
nicht so doll verbreitet bevor wir sie
dazu befragen hersteller gleich noch mal
haben wir ein grafik video vom kollegen
ja auch ein spiel sind er erklärt uns
mal so die gesamte menge leute was das
mit temperatur und viren auch sichert
frühlingsanfang vor einem jahr im
ruhrpott 22 grad im schatten
das könnten wir im chor ohne jahr 2020
wahrscheinlich gut gebrauchen denn viele
ähnliche virus arten ertragen keine
warme luft
es verhält sich damit ungefähr so wie
bei lebensmitteln
die halten sich auch besser im
kühlschrank das neue corona virus gehört
zu der gruppe der viren die von anna
lipid also einer fettschicht umgeben
sind bei wärme gehen gerade solche
umhüllten virus arten dann deutlich
schneller kaputt doch zurück zum winter
ideal für solche viren ist in dieser
zeit die eher trockene luft vor allem in
den innenräumen forscher konnten schon
mit vergleichbaren viren zeigen dass sie
sich hier besser halten und verbreiten
konnten als bei hoher luftfeuchtigkeit
im winter sind unsere schleimhäute und
atemwege ohnehin eher mal trocken und
angegriffen das neue corona virus setzt
wohl genau dort oben an
deshalb verbreitet es sich vermutlich
auch so leicht die ansteckungsgefahr ist
deutlich höher
zudem ist unser immunsystem gerade zum
ende des winters oft nicht mehr ganz auf
der höhe von anderen infekten vielleicht
schon geschwächt
allein die normale virusgrippe hat in
diesem winter bisher etwa 150000
menschen erwischt um die 250 meist
ältere patienten starben daran
mit blick auf die kommenden wochen
können uns nun der sonnen licht wärme
und die zeit draußen in der feuchten
frühlingsluft eigentlich nur helfen
trotzdem kann noch niemand genau sagen
wie sich dann das neue corona virus
tatsächlich verhalten wird so erstellen
wir haben wir alles richtig abgebildet
die asta gut aus super ist es dann
tatsächlich so dass wir sagen können
super sobald es wärmer wird können wir
die ganzen maßnahmen wieder runter
fahren oder wie lange rechnen sie dass
wir tatsächlich das öffentliche leben so
einschränken müssen
wir haben ja am anfang die hoffnungen
darauf gesetzt dass die warme jahreszeit
tatsächlich wie andere virale infekte
erkältungskrankheiten lich saisonal
bedingt zu gehen werden und es gibt
modellrechnungen aus verschiedenen
regionen die immer versucht haben zu
simulieren welchen einfluss auch
umweltfaktoren also spricht die
erwärmung haben wird auf den weiteren
verlauf der pandemie und da sieht es so
aus dass es nicht reichen wird die der
sommer dass wir ganz von dem virus
befreit werden da müssen andere faktoren
spielen eine rolle
die wärme wird sicherlich die
infektionszahlen reduzieren aber es wird
auf keinen fall wenn die modellrechnung
zu treffen
dafür sorge tragen dass das ganze
verschwindet im sommer werden wir uns
weiter unterhalten müssen über corona
via tricks fragt ihr passend dazu
facebook aber was ist in malaysia da
gibt es 30 grad und dort gibt es auch
fälle eben das ist ja genau das ist
genau der punkt wir haben auch in afrika
fälle wir haben in südeuropa südamerika
fälle und insofern australien haben wir
fälle und das sobald die sommerzeit
vielleicht hat man am anfang gedacht
wenn man sich die halbkugel angeguckt
aber die weltkugel waren alles fälle auf
der nordhalbkugel
aber ich gehe davon aus dass einfach in
vielen regionen der welt gar nicht so
intensiv getestet wird und wenn man da
mehr testen würde würde man auch im
süden mehr finden
sofern unterstützt das ja auch den die
vermutung dass der temperatur effekt
nicht so ausgeprägt sein dürfte so liebe
zuschauer weil ich gucke jetzt mal hier
ein bisschen in die kommentare was ihr
denn so schreibt robin fragt was ist so
schlimm an impfungen hätte nichts
dagegen dass es zwangsimpfungen gibt
herdenimmunität schützt ja jeden härter
halt das ist richtig robin aber es gibt
ja noch keinen impfstoff
kurze frage an herrn stürmer irgendeine
idee wenn er kommen könnte ja wir haben
jetzt ja gerade heute die meldung
bekommen dass der erste patient die
erste patientin einen neuen impfstoff
verabreicht bekommen hat eben zum testen
inwieweit ist der verträglich in die
weite gibt es nebenwirkungen und wie ist
die wirkung also es geht langsam los
aber bevor das ganze in die
massenproduktion und die massenimpfung
geht werden sicherlich noch klinische
studien folgen müssen der vorteil jetzt
ist es aufgrund der aktuellen situation
wird es sicherlich beschleunigte test
und zulassungsverfahren geben aber man
darf natürlich die sicherheit eines
solchen impfstoff ist nie außer acht
lassen und jetzt möglicherweise eben
viele menschen gefährden indem man einen
impfstoff nicht sauber testet also
insofern besonders auch ein bisschen
gedulden
die größten optimisten vom sommer
geredet ich denke mal realistisch wird
vielleicht ende des jahres sein so
sodann gibt es hier neon cortex m w
möchte wissen warum schreibt niemand wie
lange man nach der krankheit noch
ansteckend ist
gibt's da erkenntnis sachen ja es gibt
gibt es regeln wie lange man wenn man
sozusagen wieder frei getestet oder frei
rumlaufen darf in anführungszeichen
man muss mindestens zehn tage nach
ausbruch der symptome wenn man jetzt
wirklich symptome hatten zehn tage
müssen dann vergangen sein man muss
mindestens 24 bis 48 stunden fieberfrei
und tust frei auch sein und dann muss im
abstand von 24 stunden jeweils der test
zweimal negativ sein und dann geht man
nach den aktuellen regeln als nicht mehr
infektiös
ok jetzt kommt hier noch eine frage von
mischka die finde ich auch nicht
unspannend wieso nehmen wir uns kein
beispiel an anderen ländern und machen
alles für zwei wochen dicht das war es
fertig und man darf sein leben wieder
ganz normal führen das klingt logisch
ist es tatsächlich so einfach
ja man kann latif alles dicht machen wir
haben ja nahezu schon jetzt alles dicht
gemacht
es wird jetzt nur noch die
ausgangssperre soll es letztes mittel
das man noch hat aber mit 14 tagen ist
es nicht getan wir werden in 14 tagen
sehen ob diese ganzen maßnahmen was
bringen
im kontext die fallzahlen der
neuinfizierten sinken aber wenn wir zwei
wochen zu machen ist danach der ganze
spaß nicht vorbei sondern das wird uns
noch etliche monate danach beschäftigen
das heißt wie lange werden wir mit
desinfektionsmittel in einer tasche und
mit zwei meter abstand und
angeschlossenen veranstaltungsräumen
rechnen müssen oder können ich weiß das
können sie jetzt nicht wirklich sagen
aber ist es ein vier wochen sechs wochen
sechs monate oder kann ich jetzt mein
kind das irgendwie eine lungenkrankheit
hat für ein jahr weg sperren
das ist eine sehr gute frage die jemand
tatsächlich in der form noch nicht
beantworten kann wir müssen jetzt
tatsächlich abwarten wie sich die
fallzahlen nicht nur bei uns sondern
auch in natürlich in den nachbarländern
weiter entwickeln und auch sind auch
irgendwann mal zu einem abflachen der
kurven kommt die wir ja mal und liegt
definitiv nicht 10
es lohnt sich manchmal ein blick nach
china auch wenn wir den zahlen
vielleicht nicht ganz hundertprozentig
trauen können und wollen
aber da scheint es ja so langsam wieder
aufwärts zu gehen
die fallzahlen gehen zurück man fängt
langsam an die rigiden maßnahmen
zurückzuschrauben
und da ist die infektion ja schon
mindestens zweieinhalb drei monate im
gange also man sollte optimistisch mit
mindestens so zwei bis drei monaten
durchaus rechnen ja jetzt haben sie
gerade gesagt es gibt natürlich da auch
skepsis skepsis habe ich hier auch
teilweise bei den fragen es gibt aber
auch kollegen von ihnen die sind sehr
skeptisch
und es gibt den kollegen wolfgang wodarg
der ist auch virologe der geht gerade
vor allem auf youtube mit seinen videos
ziemlich stein in denen er behauptet das
alles ist im grunde nichts anderes als
das normale grippesaison die wir da
haben und
das wäre alles ein hype und ein sich
selbst bestätigen der zirkel der wo
jetzt keiner mehr sagen möchte dass das
eigentlich alles gar nicht so schlimm
ist und er hat auch gesagt es gibt immer
wieder coronaviren haben wir schon lange
da erkranken manche menschen dran
was ist da jetzt dran das ist ja doch
eine völlig andere richtung dieser
eingeschlagen wird also in einem hat er
recht corona wir kennen wir schon
relativ lange es gibt verschiedene
corona virusstämme die uns auch jede
wintersaison begleiten und für
erkältungs erkrankungen sorgen und warum
haben wir heute hier noch nie gesprochen
weil die so harmlos sind dass sie die
gar nicht merken da da kriegen sie ein
bisschen einlauf nase und husten ein
bisschen und dann war's das auch schon
also die sind nicht mit irgendwelchen
über erhöhten sterblichkeit assoziiert
und bis zu saas zeiten hat man auch
eigentlich gar keine corona virus
diagnostik gemacht und auch andere
erkältungsviren gar nicht diagnostiziert
weil es sich nicht gelohnt hat und
eigentlich klinisch nicht relevant
gewesen ist das neue virus ist eine
andere baustelle ist es zwar auch in
kona virus aber man darf nicht vergessen
dass läuft zum ersten mal durch die
menschheit durch keiner von uns ist
gegen dieses virus geschützt
wir reden im optimalen fall von 0,7 ist
ein prozent sterblichkeit ich habe ja
schon gesagt werden 50 millionen
infizierte dann 500.000 menschen die
zusätzlich versterben
das ist jetzt nicht etwas was ich
verharmlosen würde insofern kann ich dem
dem rest der äußerung da nicht zustimmen
wie kommt denn dann ein kollege von
ihnen zu so einer einschätzung ja das
müssen sie ihn fragen ja ich weiß es
ehrlich gesagt nicht und klar wenn er
jetzt das ganze mit der mit der grippe
vergleicht mit der aktuellen grippewelle
und sagt ja wir haben 250 tote und mit
19 verstorben haben wir noch mit 12
glaube ich sind die aktuellen zahlen das
ändert sich permanent und und weiß ich
jetzt nicht den aktuellen stand sind wir
natürlich davon noch weit entfernt aber
wir sind auch noch längst nicht am ende
der fahnenstange und bei der influenza
hat man natürlich immer den vorteil
gegen die kammer uns sowohl medikamentös
als auch mit einer impfung schützen das
ist also auch dann noch mal eine andere
baustelle und ich weigere mich auch
immer die influenza mit dem neuen corona
virus in der form auch eins zu eins zu
vergleichen
so jetzt gucke ich nochmal hier wir
haben hier anfragen dokument das kind
vielleicht schon wenn die live-streams
regelmäßig guckt da sind die kollegen im
hintergrund fleißig dabei alles an ich
gehe doch mal durch das sind so viele
fragen
da wir mit herrn stürmer noch zwei
stunden beschäftigt und ich glaube da
muss man irgendwann noch mal wieder als
anderes machen
ich schaue mal welche welche fragen
immer wieder aufgetreten sind das mit
den kindern hatten wir schon was dass
beim corona virus an das haben wir
gerade auch schon beantwortet wird das
virus im verlauf der ansteckungskette
aggressiver das ist vielleicht noch mal
eine interessante frage weil viren
ändern ja die ganze zeit ihre strategie
deswegen müssen wir auch jedes jahr
gegen den krieg in florenz an neu impfen
kann man das hier schon beobachten dass
dass das virus immer schlimmer wird es
ist eigentlich ist es eher der
umgekehrte weg also das virus kommt ja
eigentlich ursprünglich aus dem
tierreich und ist damit nicht
hundertprozentig an den menschen
adaptiert gut genug um vom tier zum
menschen springen zu können
aber eben noch nicht perfekt und
letztendlich wird es eigentlich eher so
sein dass die mutationen des virus
dahintreiben werden dass es sich
effektiver verbreiten kann aber auch von
der vitalität her eher harmloser wird
das ist eigentlich eher der trend den
wir beobachten
und ja die viren mutieren die influenza
ist da noch mal ein sonderfall das liegt
an der genom struktur des virus das wird
jetzt zu weit führen dass es zu erörtern
wir letztendlich ist es tatsächlich so
dass das influenza-virus sich jedes jahr
so stark verändert und neue variante
neben hochkommen als auch so viele
varianten gibt es verschiedene dass wir
deswegen jedes jahr den neuen eben stoff
brauchen wie sich das beim neuen corona
virus entwickeln wird ob wir mit einem
impfstoff durchkommen und ob er denn
dadurch ist schaffen die die pandemie
letztlich irgendwann wieder zum
einschlafen zu bringen das wird die
spannende frage der zukunft sein
eine sache gehen jetzt auch die letzten
tage immer wieder durch die medien und
da gab es mal hü mal hott muss man sagen
das war die sache mit ibuprofen so
zuerst diesen whatsapp kettenbrief dann
hieß es nein das stimmt nicht dann hat
der französische besonders minister
gesagt doch es stimmt heute hat die whu
auch davor gewarnt ibuprofen zu nehmen
wenn man mit 19 erkrankt ist also
tatsächlich diesen husten hat das ist
mir ein bisschen viel her muss ich sagen
herr stürmer können sie das mir zu
erklären wie wie das von einem tag auf
den anderen von links nach rechts gehen
kann
ja ich weiß nicht ob es zufall ist aber
ist natürlich blöd dass dass ibuprofen
jetzt in beiden dingen eine rolle spielt
erst du bist also diese wiener
geschichte definitiv ein fake hat ja
auch die wiener das wiener krankenhaus
entsprechend auch bestätigt dass sie das
nicht gesagt dass sie nicht davor
gewarnt haben so genau dass die damit
nichts zu tun haben dass das definitiv
nicht von ihnen stammt und ich glaube
auch wenn es wirklich echt gewesen wäre
hätten die kollegen das auch
entsprechend publiziert worauf sich der
französische minister bezogen hat ist
eine fall beschreibung die in einer
guten renommierten zeitschrift im lancet
publiziert worden ist keine studie
gemacht worden ist sondern beobachtet
worden ist dass relativ viele patienten
die schwerst intensiv behandelt werden
mussten ibuprofen genommen haben
inwieweit das wären und wer ist ob jetzt
wirklich die ibuprofen gabe das ganze
verschlechtert hat oder die patienten
mit ibuprofen schon vorbehandelt waren
das geht aus dieser studie dass dieser
fall beschreibung gar nicht so sehr
daraus hervor aber das hat die eu auch
ein bisschen zu meiner überraschung dazu
verleitet davor zu wahren womit sie
natürlich recht haben wenn man sich das
genau durchliest sodann hört dass sie
gesagt haben wer die symptome hat sollte
medikamente nicht ohne rücksprache mit
einem arzt nehmen
insofern haben sie nicht und definitiv
davon abgeraten gesagt das ist
gefährlich sondern man sollte es
beobachten und mit einem arzt
entsprechend sprechen und vielleicht
auch eher eine alternative zu nehmen
dass es da eindeutige beweise gibt der
also sind unsichere zeiten auch für die
medizin merken wir das ist doch eine
wissenschaft und die zu verschiedenen ja
schlussfolgerungen kommen kann und wo
wir mit dem neuen virus noch lange nicht
am ende sind wir machen den live stream
also langsam zu ich habe noch zwei drei
fragen für sie herr stürmer auf zwei
jahre pandemie müssten wir uns
vorbereiten heute was heißt denn das
heißt konkret tatsächlich zwei jahre
pandemie und dann ist es durch oder zwei
jahre müssen wir tatsächlich abstand
zueinander halten
es hängt von einigen faktoren ab wann
das möglicherweise vorbei sein könnte
es hängt davon ab wie ich was ich schon
angedeutet habe wie reagiert unser
immunsystem auf diesen erreger bekommen
wir eine lebenslange immunität nachdem
wir dass die infektion durchgemacht
haben verändert sich das virus insoweit
nicht weiter als dass wir nächstes oder
übernächstes jahr wieder neue varianten
bekommen
es kann je nachdem welche parameter ein
mann in die modelle einsetzt relativ
schnell beendet sein
es kann aber auch passieren dass dieses
virus und sowie die influenza über die
nächsten jahre und jahrzehnte permanent
begleiten wird das hängt wie gesagt
davon ab welche parameter man in die
modellrechnung einsetzt und das ist
jetzt noch so ein bisschen glaskugel
schauen und zwischen diesen varianten
wird sich irgendwann entscheiden also
fahren auf sicht würde ich das ganze mal
nennen eine sache habe ich noch nie hat
mir ein freund vor ein paar tagen
gestellt die frage die ich konnte ich
auch nicht beantworten warum waren wir
hier in nicht mehr leider so was herr
vorzusehen und was passiert wenn
tatsächlich mal ein virus ausbricht der
noch sehr viel aggressiver und schlimmer
ist und nicht ich sag mal bei den
meisten nur einen schlimmen husten
auslöst sind wir das anders gewesen
ich denke spätestens nach der
schweinegrippe saison sind die
pandemiepläne entsprechend erneuert
worden
man darf nicht vergessen wo das virus
herkommt es ist hat seinen ursprung in
china auf einem kleinen markt gehabt und
es ist zu befürchten dass china doch am
anfang versucht hat das ganze ein
bisschen auf kleiner flamme zu kochen
das vielleicht auch unterschätzt hat und
gesagt hat das schaffen wir schon da
wird nichts passieren und da darf auch
nicht schon wieder china im mittelpunkt
stehen als als
überträger oder als aus russland einer
weltweiten pandemie da hat man
sicherlich wertvolle zeit verloren
danach hat man relativ schnell die
information verbreitet so dass auch
tester entwickelt werden konnten hat die
grenzen zugemacht und sicherlich teil
dazu beigetragen dass nicht ganz so
viele infektionen durch gewandert sind
aber das ist sicherlich ein problem und
ich denke aber auch dass man auch jetzt
im umgang mit dieser pandemie wieder
dazulernen wird und jetzt auch wieder
sicherlich nationale und vielleicht auch
internationale pläne überarbeitet und
angepasst
gut dann sind wir jetzt glaube ich so
langsam am ende
es gibt ja immer wieder die frage ist
dass hessen grund zur panik oder ein
grund zur sorge
manche sagen auch mich nervt diese
mediale hype sind wir da als medien so
ein bisschen drüber über das ziel
hinausgeschossen oder ist es tatsächlich
so dass man darüber viel berichten muss
und was macht man mit den leuten die
panik schieben und sagen oh gott wir
müssen alle sterben wenn ich den letzten
satz den zitiere ich auch gerne das
haben wir zusammen zeiten intern auch
gerne immer wieder gesagt und das ist
eine realität aber die frage ist immer
nur wann also aber jetzt spaß beiseite
gehen wir wieder zurück zur frage ja es
gab sicherlich zeiten wo sehr viel über
alles mögliche berichtet worden ist zum
beispiel die schlagzeile
jetzt haben wir mehr co wird infiziert
als saas infiziert jetzt haben wir marko
wie tote als saas tote das sind so
sachen wo ich denn auch immer sagen
welchen informationsgewinn habe ich
jetzt damit verbreitet auf der anderen
seite sehe ich ja auch sowohl meine
rolle als auch die rolle der medien
möglichst viele sachliche informationen
und aufklärende information an die
bevölkerung zu übermitteln
es gibt sicherlich noch andere wege die
man hätte einschreiten können ich denke
immer noch mal so an die u bahn
haltestellen an die ins glas
straßenbahnhaltestellen unterstellen
litfaßsäulen plakatwände wo man auch
sicherlich mehr aufklärung und hinweise
hätte hin bauen können aber ich glaube
das ist ganz wichtig dass man darüber
berichtet halt eben in einer sachlichen
und vernünftigen art und weise
vielleicht zum abschluss sollten wir
noch mal sagen die meisten menschen
kommen heil durch werden geheilt dadurch
wird glaube ich auch nicht genug
berichtet kennen sie zahlen kevin
oltmanns fragte wie viele wurden bisher
geheilt
ich müsste jetzt lügen aber ich glaube
weltweit sind sind über 60.000 menschen
inzwischen sozusagen wieder aus der aus
dem krankenhaus entlassen worden
zwar gelten als geheilt jahr sind so
habe ich über 60.000 weltweit also mehr
als die hälfte gut dann hoffe ich haben
wir die meisten wichtigen fragen hier
beantwortet sorry an alle die ihre frage
jetzt nicht beantwortet bekommen konnten
aber wir werden wahrscheinlich mit
diesem virus und mit dieser pandemie
noch ein bisschen was zu tun haben der
stürmer erst mal vielen dank an sie für
ihre zeit und ich hoffe sie können dann
bald wieder zurück an die medizinische
front und helfen diese pandemie zu
bekämpfen einen schönen abend noch
ja danke ebenfalls und auch ich auch
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und für eure
ganzen fragen und kommentare wie gesagt
wir versuchen immer alles zu beantworten
das ist in diesem fall glaube ich auch
sehr wichtig aber irgendwann müssen wir
auch mal wieder gucken dass wir uns das
nicht ankommen lassen sachen
beschäftigen so dass ich noch verhaspelt
am ende schön das heißt wir machen
wirklich zu und ich wünsche euch
trotzdem noch einen schönen abend geht
nicht raus bleibt zu hause macht sich
gemütlich und in diesem sinne bis bald
[Musik]